[Musique]
c'est une scène ouverte qui a sur la
commune de Oudan le principe c'est que
les artistes ont 7 à 10 minutes voilà
pour faire une petite prestation devant
le public et on accueille tout types
d'artistes que ce soit des artistes
amateur professionnel semi-professionnel
voilà c'est ouvert à
tous c'est les jeunes un petit peu qui
ont envie qui sont de la région et qui
ont pas forcément encore envie on va
dire de se lancer sur les scènes
parisienne qui a envie de se tester un
peu en province comme on dit c'était au
niveau social et culturel à Oudan de
créer quelque chose un projet et que on
est entre guillemets un public
d'habitués que les gens se se retrouvent
régulièrement c'est très simple c'est
partout pareil tu colles ta carte contre
la machine et au bout d'une demisesee la
machine fait bip mais il y en a qui
perdent facilement patience dès que la
machine met plus de 0,8 secondes à piper
il passe en mode vibreur
genre on a retrouvé un nouveau lieu donc
qui est le restaurant la poularde à
Oudan depuis de saisons on a réduit le
nombre d'artistes à 6 plutôt que 8 et
euh tout simplement pour que voilà la
deuxième partie soit un peu plus légère
et parce qu'on sait qu'on est le jeudi
soir quand même l'entrée est totalement
gratuite on a la réservation obligatoire
pour qu'on sache le nombre de personnes
qui se présentent mais voilà ensuite il
y a une sortie au chapeau ce qui nous
permet de de rémunérer les différents
artistes au
[Musique]
chapeau